he was known as Andre in the league for
all you sports fans out there
good times watching him do that he's a
co-host of the film discussion podcast
how did this get made alongside his wife
June Rafaela and Jason Mantzoukas who is
as funny as they come as well couldn't
see you Paul thank you so much for
having and of course you're in the
disasters disaster artist insulin
theaters everywhere and it is a new
hilarious movie where James Franco and
his brother Dave are making the worst
movie ever made technically called the
room you're in it's Seth Rogen is in it
Alison Brie is in it and we'll talk
about that in a second
are you playing fantasy football still
do you get that question all the time I
do and I am and right now it's a really
sore spot for me because I was having an
amazingly solid season that just fell
apart
like in the last two weeks like well
with basically three weeks ago I tied
the worst person in our entire league so
that was a real up that was a real blow
for me to tie the worst person and then
just two solid losses were in their
playoffs now and I'm just like just done
I'm done you're done
dead in the water yeah I mean who's on
your team Mariota like who I feel like
she's been really tough and I had you
know I've got two and I'm a I'm a right
you know a Rams fan or I'm trying to be
a Rams fan and this year made it really
actually easy last year was way harder
is it oh yeah
cuz I'm a Jets fan and I was like you
know what I have kids now I want to have
a team that we can like enjoy together
maybe go and jets or not that to you and
if also says I moved out here I mean I'm
in dire straits right now because I'm
also a Clippers fan and that's a whole
nother issue of just pain my god so you
could be Lakers Giants instead you're
Jets Clippers yeah but yes so my team is
going is just it's just not doing
anything on the board at all and I
thought like I was gonna I thought I was
gonna be one of those sneaky players it
just puts up a solidly good season and
then you know get I I thought I was you
know of course I thought I was gonna win
but no now
I'm just eating it everywhere the last -
what's your team name my team name is oh
gosh
I changed it because it was offensive
what which league are you in I'm in a
league with Jerry O'Connell one of the
worst fantasy football players I've ever
played with who else is in there Scott
Armstrong Errol elf and Starsky and
Hutch Adam pally
you know from happy endings oh my gosh
who else is in this thing a bunch of
people like that okay but the run living
the League League no longer Ron
Livingston problem yes
yeah huh does he have a bunch of bears
because that's what is wrong Ron seems a
little absentee this year Oh Matt Walsh
isn't it - yeah we've all talked about
there yeah I know there's all Bears okay
yeah it's Ron's a little bit absent this
year in it I'm not in the league with
the guys from the league anymore simply
because I feel like most of those people
did not want to play in that league and
it was an eight-team League and that was
a team or I always felt great about
myself you know cuz of a team league you
could pick up people on the waiver wire
you could have a crap eat everything was
at your disposal right this this one I'm
in now is just a monstrosity you know
with my draft badly I'm done you're not
done yeah Paul Scheer here on the Rich
Eisen show so so you are have you gone
to a Rams game this year a Rams game
this year I went last year basically and
this sounds lame I'm a parent and though
I have a tune a pad a kid right now and
my wife is not going to be psyched about
me while I go watch Jared golf joke on
the Eagles this yeah I almost lose and
then come back at the end but you know
the tricky thing is going to LA like a
game in LA it takes you almost as long
as the game to get in and out of the
parking - so that's now full day right
trip it's not like an easy Internet well
it seems to me that the Rams in Los
Angeles got a bunch of fans interested
just cuz they returned unfortunately for
them put a Jeff Fisher and then Jeff
Fisher fired product on the field now
this is a much better product and now
people are paying attention but haven't
really physically shown up Village
eight and and like it's the stadium is
comically empty and it's it's so sad
when everything my friends at the game
it's like it's and that's a giant
Stadium - I mean it is it already is
predisposed to look empty and it looks
even more in well there's gonna be a lot
of eagles fans there this weekend I know
that
yeah and cuz Brockman you're one of
those Rams fans that are selling their
tickets right you you you have your
tickets they're on the second day have
they sold yet and I season tickets and I
was like why because anytime I can
actually go I'll be able to get great
that's right I'm gonna be out of town
and be on a plane coming back oh oh so
you ready champ yeah yeah okay so you're
not just gonna be sitting here no I'm
not gonna yeah right okay what do you
think the vibe is like there though
because I've been like I went there I've
seen like three games right and it's
it's a real mixed button it's a very
mixed crowd it's a it's like it's like
Raider Nation light yes it's a very
rowdy well I'll tell you this if the
Rams win the division and get a home
click playoff game ok and and so if that
happens it will either be on a Saturday
night I believe that in that spot
Saturday night Rams versus let's say
right now could be Falcons coming in
here could be Seahawks coming in here
could be that could be Rams versus
Carolina could be rams or Packers and
they would put that on a Saturday night
or maybe that Sunday afternoon game I
think you would get 80 90 thousand
people here for that I would hope so I
don't know I'll shake would that be if
that happened it would be amazing I just
think honestly part of my issue is it's
just it's a mech that stadium is a mess
it's like to get in to get out it's like
it's a particle it's old but old they're
refurbishing it not but just then it's
gonna be too expensive for anyone today
and that's what bums me out I was in
Atlanta I want to go see a Falcons game
and that Stadium amazing I love a
stadium like right in the middle of the
city like New Orleans is great like that
too you can walk to it you can leave
from it it's perfect I do LA I walk into
a Saints game there's nothing like that
watching everybody who's had the blue
flu for the last 10 hour
skipping out on work and just getting so
well-oiled for the evenings affair when
I saw the Super Bowl in New Orleans it
was one of the best experiences because
you know you casually walk into the same
you and then when as soon as it went out
you could just walk right into anything
right right there plus you were on the
league on FX and I'm sure you got some
good tickets for them oh yeah yeah we
got wait here we go to the game ah let's
take a break we'll come back in sixty
Seconds to talk about that with you as
well as this movie about one of the
worst movies ever made and I want to
know what you think is the worst movie
that's absolutely that Paul Scheer when
we come back here in 60 seconds still to
come as well the pitch Friday subject
about what you think is in the Rafael
Palmero of contract as he comes back
from 53 years of age that's coming up
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show the
my pillow buy one get one free offer is
still available when you go to my pillow
comm click on the buy one get one free
tab take advantage of this limited time
offer by putting the promo code rich in
and then you get a ability to get a free
my pillow premium pillow when you
purchase one of them and it comes with a
10 year warranty and a 60 day money back
guarantee trust me we all love these
pillows I love this fellows you do too I
do I like on my pillow i I thought well
she loves my well because I heard the
laugh event when I saw the guy with the
moustache running around touching
people's pillows and there's like I
gotta check this thing out and it
actually is really cuff it's great it's
really good I got a dryer when you get
it and then boom it's it's ready to go I
am a my pillow convert atta boy
Paul Scheer loves it we all love it let
Paul shears pillow become your pillow
it's my fellow cop the disaster artist
is in theaters everywhere right now
James Franco is playing its directs it
as well a movie about the making of a
movie called the room would you how many
central runs I guess once a year it's
like their Christmas story yeah it's
it's an impossible movie to get your
hands on because the guy who created it
tommy was though who is just from Europe
in quotes that's as much specifics as we
get from him only we'll sell it on his
website so you have to PayPal him money
to get the DVD doesn't stream anywhere
and
only goes through him they'll sell you
underwear DVDs scripts whatever you want
and and the movie is amazing
it's like Tennessee Williams put through
google translate you know it's just a
nothing quite it makes sense but it
feels like there is a motion coming I
just don't understand what the emotions
are right and yeah so I got a addicted
to this movie and I watch it it was on
my mind was blown I wanted to watch it
again immediately and then I did this
podcast with Greg Sestero one of the
actors in the movie also the line
producer of the movie come on and he
told me about him and Tommy this kind of
weird relationship and I didn't know
about Tommy basically back then and then
when they got to do this movie based on
his book that he wrote after our podcast
it was like a dream come true is that
going like it was like basically getting
to like a live in my my biggest fantasy
look which is the room which is the
crappiest movie of all time right and
you play the DP on the set for those who
may not know a DP is he like does all
the director of photography so he's
doing the lighting and everything now
the lighting on the room is is bad I
mean every day like look the the million
centerpieces of the room is a roof which
is ironic but like so they're on a roof
but the roof is all green screen they
could have shot on a real roof but they
decided the green screen a green screen
and Seth Rogen plays the the director
and there's a great script supervisor
okay who so basically we're like the
Waldorf and Statler of the middle is
what our limits reading yeah the old
guys Muppet reference and so there's
some other great cameos in this yeah
anything Bryan Cranston I know has been
on this show he's in it Nathan fielder's
in it
everywhere you look Megan Mullaly all
the like every single part is has an
amazing cast and it's in theaters
everywhere right now what do you think
is the worst movie ever made I have to
say and not because I'm here to talk
about the disasters but I do believe the
room is the apex of because most bad
movies make like 75% wrong choices right
this movie makes a hundred percent wrong
choices and all the negatives make a
positive and you're like I need to watch
this again and again but a close second
yes is a movie called Miami connection
directed and written by Taekwondo master
YK Kim it's a movie about cocaine rock
and roll and ninja
and it's called Miami connection but
it's all about cocaine and Orlando so I
don't know and and the ninjas are in a
band called dragons sound and there's
like four or five musical numbers that
are pretty good in it just rocking out
yeah my only connection you can find it
on online and the funny story about that
was a guy at the Alamo Drafthouse which
they play all these kind of great movies
at the Alamo Drafthouse right this on
eBay
and he saw Miami connection let go the
two reels of film and he bought it for
$30 didn't know what it was unspooled it
and then found this masterpiece and then
bought it and re-released it Paul Scheer
here on the Rich Eisen show I've only
walked out of two movies but were they
okay have you ever walked out of a movie
thing I have like it's just this is so
bad even though I'm in a movie theater
it's the hardest decision to make
because it's like what else am I gonna
do I mean I've already committed the
time convinced yeah you're here what
have you ever walked out of a movie I
have I walked out on anger management
really yes I will say this was like 12
years ago whenever that came on it was
the back end of a double dip let's just
say every episode of anger management
the TV show two movies okay I walked out
of funny farm well this was you know
when I would see anything Chevy Chase
did because the vacation movie yeah and
Fletch yeah and I even saw Fletch - of
Fletch - I stayed from beginning to end
for but I walked out a funny farm my
buddies in the late 80s and you know
when I'm in I'm in high school yeah when
we walked out of it and then um due date
with Robert Downey and Zack get the one
of the buddy trains and automobiles but
just not Z and I we were absolutely
1,000% into you know life of them Robert
Downey jr. coming off of iron man's that
Cal factors coming off the hangover that
this
is going to be comedy gold he was coming
also off of Tropic Thunder as well and
we're like in in and then we were I
think this is like our firstborn was
like a year and a half yeah we get so
rare to get out of course let's go get
something eat left the only thing with
now with my wife and I when we get out
no matter what the quality of the movie
is we're like we loved it like whatever
because I think we're just like excited
to be out exactly what you like that
movie like yeah we weren't at home
I loved it here kids ruin every fact
basically I so I can one-up both of your
stories and say that I pulled out of a
movie cuz I saw it I did drive-in I
literally pulled my car out of the
driver in the middle of beer fest which
is like the guys who did like Super
Troopers and stuff like that like they
made a movie called beer fest you know I
was like let's go
we gotta go just and that that's the
most uncomfortable leaving because
you're slowly moving at least you can
walk out of a movie think you bathroom
we're gonna get some popcorn yeah we're
driving out you're pretty much you're
making a statement and Paul Scheer here
on the show Paul your perfect person
have here you know we do this sometimes
with guests we're here this show has a
relationship with Funny or Die yes don't
have anything you just sit here we have
a relation with Funny or Die they have
an app called pitch where there are
topics on the app the threads if you
will sort of like @midnight
Yeah right where writers write lines for
it and we have our viewers and listeners
chime in with their answer to a Funny or
Die pitch thread and if we choose your
answer you get an invitation to the
invitation-only comics only writers only
app community of four pitch and and
where they pay for jokes so people can
get started in the comedy career okay
here we go so the top five answers did
we sort of rip off Letterman here yeah
because I'm sitting better
top five answers of provisions in 53
year old a major league baseball
comeback candidate Rafael Palmeiro's
potential contract number five not
allowed to use his cane as a bat
number four clubhouse must be fully
stopped with new Gatorade prune blast
number three
preparation HGH number two walk-up music
played at a reasonable volume 8 p.m. and
in the number one provision in Rafael
Palmeiro's potential contract for his
comeback at age 53 is salary must be
more than what Bobby Bonilla is
currently making and that was written by
Michael Tannenbaum of New York New York
not not Mike Tannenbaum of southern
Florida general manager of the Miami
Dolphins and the listener viewer
submission at LA Kings fan er
congratulations DM us your information
because you win this pitch Friday topic
saying that Rafael Palmeiro and his
contract on his giveaway night
Palmeiro's bobblehead must double as a
life alert device I love it they're
funnier dog
so tell that story before you take off
about the Super Bowl
yes you think they're gonna treat us
good you know it's its effects we do a
show about football like we get put in
that was a blackout Super Bowl two so
there's a lot of this was Niners Raven
yes
so we're there and ours this so bad our
seats are that so I think it was a year
that Beyonce was performing with
Destiny's Child right they can't that
was a surprise donors child popped up
yes
so Beyonce gets out there she's saying
she's dancing and then these like giant
slats come up yes boom boom boom and
we're both locked off from the entire
halftime show all I saw was fireworks
like but like and there's something
amazing going on in front of this wall
that we were not able to see and that
stadium is so kind of old but there's no
screens like so they weren't playing
anything so we just sat in like silence
and you know when
you're in the stadium during Super Bowl
it's longer than anything and we had
nothing to look at but just like
occasionally sparks like we'd hear stuff
it was the fastest spot to sit in real
real bit two words for you
yeah basic cable I'm sure Boreanaz had
two on the 50 because he was a known a
hundred percent yeah we're on we were at
that point on FXX
get our show through Morse code I
remember man my first Sports Center that
I was at ESPN for first world series I
was on SportsCenter ESPN is 96 lifelong
Yankee fan Yankees back in the World
Series for the first time since 1981 and
I thought to myself all for those years
if I ever get to SportsCenter how great
would that be I go to World Series
whatever it no I to be a Ford holder
it's there I am sitting at my desk
watching the World Series and who had
tickets right there because she had a
new series on Fox was 2d
Kim fields sitting there I'm like Kim
fields is at this World Series
I'm on SportsCenter I'm gonna middle
Connecticut watching it on television
those refabricated cubicle down those
are the moments that I get when I watch
sports do not care about writing there's
promotional gimmick and I get it gets me
I have season tickets to the Clippers I
set up high at the Clippers and then I
look down I'm like this idiot
this dumb movies getting the best seats
or Clippers game yeah no but at least
Kadeem Hardison really is a fan right
he's really in look look right now the
Clippers are having a lot of problems
I'm the guy who wears the Clippers
outfit is on strike right now Cheryl
yeah clipper Darrell is on strike that I
knew but I thought you meant the guy who
puts that Condor outfit on Paul Scheer
good to see you here everybody should go
see the disaster artist in theaters
everywhere in some places in IMAX all
very good the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience